[Music]
myanmar is a country on the brink of
collapse
hundreds of thousands of people have
taken to the streets to protest against
a military coup they have been met with
brutal force
over 3 800 people have been arrested
many have been tortured and at least 780
have been killed in street battles the
military seized control on february 1st
after the election commission rejected
their unfounded claims of voter fraud in
the november general election
aung sang soo chi the de facto leader of
myanmar
is being detained under trumped-up
charges
following her resounding re-election in
november
what does this mean for the rest of asia
and what's being done
to stop the country sliding into further
chaos
our experts answer your questions
where is angsang tsuchi and what will
happen to her
she hasn't been seen since the coup
she's currently under house arrest
and i'm afraid she's likely to remain in
jail
very much very likely for the rest of
her life um
she's currently been charged with uh six
offenses ranging from the
ludicrously minor offense of illegally
importing
walkie-talkies to much more serious
offenses for instance of
accepting bribes and and breaking the
official secrets act
the army clearly trumped up some charges
because they want to get aung san tsuchi
out of the way
but it all hinges on whether the army's
really able to assert control
um and if it isn't you know if some kind
of compromise has to be brokered then
then
you know we could see aung san tsuchi in
power again
i think she could become a kind of
bargaining chip
in negotiations between the generals the
shadow government this is composed of
deposed mps from her own party
and the international community which is
trying to broker talks
but we first have to get to the
negotiating table and we're
very far away away from that now what
are myanmar's powerful neighbors
india and china doing about this china
has responded in a very
uh ambiguous fashion um when the coup
first happened it described it as a
major cabinet reshuffle
um china has extensive interests in
myanmar
it views myanmar as being an important
notch
on its belt and road it's massive
infrastructure project
um and it is very keen to see those
investments
be protected so it's it's i i think
basically
um china's stance is we don't really
mind who's in power
as long as our interests are being take
being taken care of
india's also sort of wary of of china's
interest in myanmar china seems to see
myanmar as a potential
outlet to the indian ocean and uh
and that's something that that i think
india is keen to curtail
but there's a lot going on in india at
the moment a a terrible second wave of
kirby 19
um lots of very hard fought uh state
elections
and a government that itself has some
sort of authoritarian tendencies uh
isn't
isn't that keen to to be sort of
stumping for democracy
around the world so india's response has
really been
quite muted why aren't western countries
and the un
intervening and what should they do
western countries are actually
intervening um they
have placed sanctions on the senior
general
um his his cronies within the military
um on their on their business interests
the un
isn't going to do anything except for
issues strongly word statements
and that is because china and russia sit
on the security council
and will have vetoed any efforts
to do something more robust this is
because um
china is loath to annoy whoever is in
charge in myanmar
and russia is in the same camp
actually interestingly russia's deputy
defense minister
showed up at the army's big bash it's
armed forces day
uh recently in in late march so russia
is very keen to keep
the army happy russia is another major
arms supplier
um to the generals and they don't want
to lose out on on the army's custom the
only thing sort of
beyond those kind of sanctions that many
burmese
actually have been calling for many many
of the student protesters have been
calling for
is to literally sort of send troops and
overturn the coup
but myanmar is just too far away and too
little known
and there's too little appetite for that
kind of conflict the idea that
america or any european country would
intervene by force um is is just
fanciful unfortunately so so um
uh i think the most that can be hoped
for is some kind of
smart sanction regime that sort of makes
life difficult
and um awkward for for the generals
how is the rohingya refugee crisis
affected by the situation
in myanmar so for decades the army has
demonized muslims and also rohingyas and
said that they do not belong
in the country and in 2017 um
they went on a kind of murderous rampage
um throughout this
rohingya community um raping
pillaging murdering causing some some
seven hundred thousand to to flee
to bangladesh um so there's been this
refugee crisis
uh pla afflicting the burmese government
and also
neighboring bangladesh um for several
years now there are now over a million
ranges in the camps in bangladesh
now the rohingyas were very critical of
aung san tsuchi and her government for
failing to resolve the crisis
and for failing to kind of create the
conditions that would allow for them to
to go home
so they were no fans of aung san tsuchi
um but they cannot be happy um
that their persecutors are are now in
government
um shortly after the coup the senior
general said
he made some noises about wanting to
bring the rohingya home
but that was clearly just a ploy to
placate the west
um they're going to do nothing about the
rohingyas
even if there were to be um some kind of
restoration of a democratic government
unfortunately there's a very strong
anti-muslim prejudice within myanmar
and it's hard to imagine
even if other uh minority ethnic groups
um
are are given a sort of fairer treatment
by by the burmese state
it it's quite hard to imagine that that
the whole country will turn over a new
leaf when it comes to the rohingyas
unfortunately
what effects will there be on
neighbouring countries and asia as a
whole
if myanmar becomes a failed state the
most obvious one
that that has been a problem for a very
long time in myanmar
is drugs so uh myanmar was a a big
center
uh for heroin production for a long time
it still is but it has more recently
become
the world's biggest producer of
methamphetamines
and that's those are made they're
synthetic drugs made
in these um sort of borderlands where it
where it's not clear who's in charge and
where
both some of these ethnic militias and
uh some
army officers are are making money
through drug smuggling
um that problem will presumably
proliferate and it's already very big
um and then there are the other problems
associated with with the the fighting
and the protests and the turmoil going
on
um there are already some refugees
crossing into thailand and into
india there have been some cases of
covert that the whole health system has
broken down during all the
or the protests and demonstrations um
and
uh so no one's really tracking covert
anymore but some covert cases showed up
uh on the chinese side of the burmese
border
to the alarm of the chinese authorities
um presumably
we'll see more of that kind of thing
it's not going to sort of cause total
chaos but but
all of these factors drugs disease
refugees they're going to sort of breed
instability in the surrounding countries
could civil war break out
myanmar has never been at peace you know
not since
it um it won independence from the from
the british the colonial power
um has it really been that peace so
there are these ethnic minorities
um in the in the pockets so the borders
of the country
um that have been waging wars of
independence
against the sort of central government
um all this while what we're seeing now
i think for the first time however in
burmese history
is the bamar the ethnic majority
from which the army derives its
its troops its soldiers the bama are
starting to turn
on the army um hundreds
some say thousands of of bamar
are streaming from the the heartland of
the country
into the borderlands into these um
territories controlled by ethnic
militias to get training
and are either joining those militias um
or coming back
to the heartlands in order to wait to
kind of guerrilla war against
um against the army so we're seeing the
makings of
of a kind of new front in this um
sort of forever civil war that's been
raging in myanmar
what began as a very peaceful protest
movement because
of the incredible brutality of the
army's response has
has already become a sort of low-level
insurrection where
we're all across the country including
in the in the bomber heartland
um city dwellers villagers
are are resisting the army in whatever
way they can in including
violently so um you know it's very
uneven the
the one side has all the weapons in
effect um but i'd
say it already resembles a civil war
what's the best strategy to restore
democracy
can the protesters succeed if the shadow
government
is able to enlist the the support
of enough of these ethnic militias
um that would be that would be one thing
now
the ethnic militias aren't big enough to
take down the army by themselves
but if they all kind of collectively
started working together
they could spread the army very very
thin
and should the kind of economic pressure
being applied
um you know last for
months several years
and the spoils of war don't start to
sort of filter down to the rank and file
that could that could start to distress
rank and file soldiers who will also
not be enjoying the kind of um a program
that they will be receiving from their
communities you know
who will be very upset with them um for
siding
with their oppressors so the shadow
government hopes
that um with the with the strikes with
the civil disobedience movement
and with the federal army that it hopes
to
amass um it will basically encourage
enough
soldiers from within the army um to
defect to either desert
um or defect to their side to the
federal army side
what are the factors that cause a
country to become a failed state
and will myanmar become one if you look
at the countries that are
widely acknowledged to be failed states
around the world um the the other
obvious one
within asia is afghanistan um the
problem is
that there's no one really in charge um
there are various people
claiming the right to run the country
but but but no one
who's actually able to assert their
authority over the whole country
um and and that is already true in
myanmar
that may be a temporary situation it
could be
that um with its brutal tactics
um the army basically sort of grinds
down the protests and and very slowly
reasserts control um but
even if that happens and that probably
unfortunately is the is the likeliest
outcome
but but if that does happen the army
will then inherit a country that's been
totally laid waste so
even under those circumstances it's hard
to say that the
you know it will be a normal country it
will take
years to rebuild the administration um
to to rebuild the infrastructure um to
sort of get the country working again
and and i think in addition to the the
tragedy of
um uh the overthrow of of burmese
democracy
um you know that's a whole second
tragedy now unfolding
that whatever uh government uh prevails
uh
in the the welfare of ordinary uh
burmese has been set back massively
i'm edward mcbride the economist asia
editor
you can read more about the protest in
myanmar by clicking the link
thank you for watching and don't forget
to subscribe